as i just mentioned the sanctions on
russia have not stopped president
vladimir putin at least not yet over the
weekend he put his nuclear forces on
high alert raising new fears of a
nuclear war for more on all of it let's
go now to retired army lieutenant
colonel alexander vinman lieutenant
colonel good morning to you you have a
unique cross-section of expertise here
you're born in ukraine came to america
as a three-year-old rose to positions of
expertise as the person specializing in
russia for the joint chiefs of staff in
our government and then the national
security council so few people know more
than you from all sides of the equation
i'm curious at this point how we get out
of a dynamic where everyone says we have
to stop vladimir putin but everyone also
acknowledges that sanctions are not
enough so what more needs to be done
what can be done
so vladimir putin is hoping through his
nuclear saber rattling that he'll put us
back on our heels he'll get us to be
deeply concerned about this potential
for nuclear escalation but of course uh
for those in government they understand
that the history is
we've had to deal with this threat
throughout throughout the cold war
throughout the soviet uh period for
generations for a couple generations and
that we had to respond to russia's
belligerence and stay firm and uh
in supporting our national security
interests so that's part of it is just
not to bend because of the nuclear saber
rattling because we've seen it before
but the other thing we need to do is we
need to indicate that his actions have
severe consequences on the economic
scale we've not never executed anything
like this for all intents and purposes
russia's economy is isolated there'll
still be some energy flows because
europe relies on them but it's an
isolated economy it's going to have a
devastating impact and then on the
military landscape which is a
particularly acute at the moment the
provisioning of ukraine with with lethal
assistance including these former
soviet aircraft are going to be
extremely important as ukraine's air
force has been
significantly degraded the provision of
anti-tank capabilities the provision of
air defense capabilities but there's
more that we need to be doing we need to
provide uavs that have been highly
effective these uh unmanned aerial
vehicles that strike deep targets but
that's probably where we need to go
before we really start to
force vladimir putin to thinking about
off ramps he's the one that initiated
this war he's the one that's going to
make the first signals that he's he's
willing to go ahead in a different
direction but we're far from that point
still well we hope we get to that point
colonel i have a quick follow-up on the
nuclear sable rattling i hear you saying
we shouldn't be concerned uh he's done
this in the past but there are others
saying that he is not the same vladimir
putin he was five ten years ago he's
changed what makes you think from where
you're sitting that he's still a
rational actor and i think you know what
i mean by that
yeah well he hasn't changed he's not a
madman he's not suicidal he's actually
been increasingly incrementally
increasing his aggression against uh the
west for for years i mean we he used
nuclear um grade materials to poison
adversaries chemical weapons
uh he's targeted u.s forces with
bounties he's conducted multiple wars
and he's not the problem is that he
hasn't faced a significant reaction now
he's facing that reaction this is
something that he's unaccustomed to but
he's not a madman and he's going to once
he realizes that this is legit this has
a major bite and he's not achieving his
military objectives in ukraine he's
going to look for other ways to achieve
his uh aims in the long run thank you
colonel in a recent op-ed in the in the
atlantic you said that biden granted
putin a free hand
how so
well it's it's really um multiple
administrations 20 years of failed
policy and uh what that did was that
kind of put blinders on to the to the
broader landscape with regards to
ukraine so what you what you have is um
the administration kind of looking at
russia through a soda straw within that
soda straw the binding administration's
leaned very far forward
they're on the leading edge of these
issues sanctions they're not providing
weapons but um there's more that could
have been done we could see now the
catastrophe that this war is and that
the
likelihood of being limited and the us
stays out of it cleanly or europe stays
out of it cleanly is unrealistic so my
my critique was mainly to learn from our
mistakes to stop an incrementalist
approach and to really start providing
the kind of support to ukraine that they
need so that's not the 350 million that
the us promised but an order of
magnitude bigger 3.5 billion and start
thinking about a 35 billion yet
colonel i wanted to talk to you about
the ukrainian people no it's okay many
people are in awe
and in awe of the
the resolve and the determination of the
ukrainian people i saw an interview with
the mayor of kiev who said we are
pressed but we are not depressed
which i thought was very powerful based
on what you know about ukraine and its
people what do you make of how they're
handling this
it's amazing
they are a shining example for the
entire world certainly
our own population here in the
uh
u.s
is drawn to it and we we always love the
underdog story but it's more than that
this is a resilient tough people
fighting for their freedom fighting for
democracy fighting for their homes and
it
it's the russians were certainly not
prepared for it they had some failed
false assumptions and they're being
ground down uh on those battlefields in
ukraine uh but it's an amazing people uh
some
a population that i've gotten a chance
to know that is in my blood also for
that matter and i'm very very proud to
call myself a ukrainian american
yeah they're more afraid of losing their
country and their independence and
they're of losing their lives and so
they fight colonel vinman thank you very
much